[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous les shérifs yallo
baba on laisse on dirait qu'il est 17h40
à la poubelle et s'habille comme c'était
une musique ne fait pas de mal on est
très bien de merde si ya pas de chance
d'être avec nous il ya plein d'invités
qui voulaient nous voir parce que c'est
j moins 3 bien sûr avant la fin de ce
soir chez ba ba et à l'aube à banias
bouder qui veulent arriver comme des
halls à la haye je vois elie semoun qui
est là bas nous savamment d'élite al
moore et lee et elie élise je te dire
voilà je te dis que je t'ai toujours
aimé et la vidéo qu'a posté sur un site
avec ton avec ton papa franchement t'as
pas envie mais j'avais envie de
t'embrasser voilà et je peux le dit moi
aussi je t'adore moi aussi je t'adore
comme son papa ça va il va bien il va
bien marc-antoine le bret qui est là ça
va mon marquant salué le sérieux ça va
bonjour avant mon chéri est on dit voilà
rien mais je crois qu'on va travailler
ensemble beaucoup l'année prochaine je
viens d'être pauvre est pas encore les
cherry est qu'est ce qui vous manque le
plus là pendant le confinement qu'est ce
que vous allez faire des vagues dès
qu'on fini c'est quoi le truc qui vous
manquent vraiment le plus
ça peut être un truc tout con prendre un
verre ça peut être marcher dans la rue
c'est quoi c'est quoi philippe c'est
quoi le truc qui me manque le plus à
apprendre mais incontestablement aller
boire un coup et les copains tu voyais
se foutent à une terrasse de café et se
dire qu'on va enfin pouvoir s'embrasser
rigoler ricaner jimmy choo qui est en
train d'essayer de se connecter avec wii
est avec toi 10h30 et mission la plus
urgente est là le regard de mon père
quand il fait sur facetime est comme ça
parc antoine est ce qu'on peut organiser
une discussion entre chantal ladesou la
dre chantal ladesou et marc-antoine le
bret ans chantal ladesou gasser ya de
l'école à
dans les bons jours que je ne me vois
pas mais je vous présente en bas ça
c'est fait ouais hein c'est gentil alors
à part votre vidéo et arrêtez-vous à
l'épaule et aux caisses par là elle même
je crois les spectateurs vous regardent
et disent est ce que les stars vivent
comme nous le confie de mon moi je me
lève tôt ce que je dors mal
ouais keller genre tôt savoir monde
après je vais dans mon jardin je vais
pisser sur mon compost
paris paris regarder les abeilles après
je regarde mon téléphone
après j'essaye de me faire à manger je
suis complètement nul pour pour manger
après souvent j'appelle franck dubosc
ont plein de vidéos ensemble donc on
essaye de trouver des bonnes idées
après moi je bouge pas mal je vais je
vais faire des courses je m'emmerde quoi
en faire eric zemmour c'est le quart
d'heure sans filtre c'est parti vous
êtes une affaire qui depuis plusieurs
jours est au coeur de toutes les
polémiques sur internet la vidéo d'un
jeune homme qui agressent dans la rue le
polémiste eric zemmour
moi je soutiens non seulement eric
zélande et je soutiens un site très
simple c'est que nul ne devrait être
victimes d'agressions verbales ou
physiques au motif qu'on ne partage pas
ses opinions ce n'est pas une manière
d'exprimer nos clients ensuite je
n'appellerai pas le jeune homme je
l'appellerai la racaille moi je serai
toujours
alors moi je n'aime pas ce mot j'aime
pas ce mot eric je te dis la vérité je
passe d'armé mais moi j'aime j'aime pas
ce mot je te le dis ben brahim a dit le
meilleur ça veut dire ça veut dire quoi
une racaille eric ça veut dire quoi ira
glass inconscient ce monde ouvert
guillot voilà pour moi je ne regarde pas
ce oui oui j'aime pas sur moi je trouve
que je trouve très important peu importe
le nom simplement je veux pas parler à
la place d'eric zemmour ils apprennent
élèves sucer son choix je peux redire
juste que en ce qui le concerne pour ce
qui me concerne
nous avons déjà été victimes
d'agressions plus violente que celle ci
et qui n'ont pas été filmé et dont il ya
pas de trace film et vous vous avez déjà
été pris à partie dans la rue très
souvent oui bien sûr je vous le dis je
n'entre pas dans les détails mais de
manière beaucoup plus violente que ce
que vous avez montré dans la vidéo avec
avec des mots et quand vous avez été
confronté à ça quand vous êtes face à 10
personnes qui vous insu
qui vous intimide physiquement vous
voyez la chose un peu autrement et c'est
à jouer les oiseaux de mauvaise augure
puisque je vous parle pas de ce qui va
arriver je vous parle de ce qui est
arrivé est pareil la semaine prochaine
on va être en prenez déconfinement on a
envie de dire un avec l'équipe on aura
voilà des chroniques j'aurai des
chroniqueurs à mes côtés on va il est en
train de faire un plateau avec tous vos
rendez-vous les coups de coeur les coups
de griffes qui se passe à la télé hier à
la télé tout ce que vous aimez le quart
d'heure sans fil vous allez retrouver
toutes vos tous vos rendez vous donc la
semaine prochaine vous allez retrouver
des bases d'al un piano si puisqu'on va
jouer voilà il y aura il y aura la paix
qu tentures à dire fléchettes y aura de
la poubelle c'est à dire une poubelle
avec une balle au ras du oui et tu
repars tout nous alors moi c'est moi qui
fais et je voulais vous dire merci de
votre fidélité
je vous jure c'est vrai hier vous étiez
encore 700 milles à nous regarder c'est
incroyable qu'on avait l'impression
d'être j'étais chez vous voilà on avait
l'impression de vivre voilà on sent dead
de vivre les mêmes choses et c'est vrai
que c'était une expérience qui restera
pour moi un excellent souvenir enfin de
vous avoir accompagné c'est vrai que
tout ça ça restera un mauvais souvenir
pour nous toute cette histoire de kobe
19 et on espère que ça va ça va
s'arranger bien entendu mais c'est vrai
que le fait de vous avoir accompagné le
fait d'avoir été avec vous et de vous
avoir senti aussi proche de moi et mon
approche de bout j'espère c'était un
super souvenir
valérie benaïm chabal et mais là il m'a
donné ni les ont tant donné qu'on a
l'impression qu'elle est dans dans vous
savez l'émission c'est quoi déjà comment
s'appellent les soumissions de soir
voyage au bout de la nuit exactement
on va essayer je vous dans un petit truc
tu as sur twitter est-ce que vous pouvez
remplacer le mot boulettes dans un livre
boulettes et dans un salaire ballon
vieux sous les boulettes
voilà non mais c'est vrai je vois là
voilà il arrive d'ailleurs à la hauteur
de la boulette part du très bien benhaim
bravo lâchez-moi les bullets 1 c'est un
livre aux attentes sachez que sophy je
crois qu'ils font dans la pub que tu es
bien la jce je crois que tu m'as
dessinée j'aimerais qu'on demande aux
téléspectateurs
[Rires]
non mais là n'est pas le débat c'est
bouder ces bouteilles et les dérivés
chez vous mais réagissent et odessa de
ce huis clos décidé le il s'est habillé
en tenue du moyen-âge qu'il est
magnifique regard des deux bras au kiné
beau tu es beau le corps tout lui va
tout lui va
je sais pas alors je lance la stat tout
lui va d'ailleurs je le lance pour vous
donnez moi vos impressions hashtag tout
libanais pour rené mais regardez moi
mais regardez-moi 6 et 7 mai mais cette
classe mais regardez-moi ces beautés
club de foot que nous pas où est clap de
fin
des routes des routes pour baba ce soir
c'est baba s'arrête
bon je vous nettoie on s'arrête pas du
lit sans prévenir aucun chroniqueur
merci tu peux tu veux aller boire un
petit verre toi tranquille les applaudir
bravo les échos
et voilà le réalisateur aussi niveau la
quille qui a été formidable bijoux dit
voilà ce alors l'émission on va la faire
ce soir on va faire une dernière et
après bien sûr la semaine prochaine on
va se retrouver dans un nouveau plateau
et loire pour une nouvelle émission qui
s'appellera c'est que du kif
on va parler d'art cas médias olympiades
je pense que ça va vous plaire on veut
vous détendre la voilà je vous dis
jusqu'à la fin juin jusqu'au 18 juin 28
juin je sais pas jusqu'à quand on va
aller 2 juillet en tout cas on va être
dans la détente puisque après le 18 mai
il ya à prendre ou à laisser qui arrive
donc les boîtes et bien sûr c'est que du
kif à 19h à prendre à l'essai à 20
heures et je vous dis pour la rentrée je
vous prépare un retour de tp
exceptionnel pelouse jure que c'est vrai